في وسط هذه الحديقة الوطنية ،
يوجد دليل صارخ على جمال
الطبيعة وإبداع هندسة العصر الفيكتوري ، تم تحقيق
هذه القصة الكبيرة العظيمة
من قبل مجلس السياحة الوطني الألماني
وهانس زيمر لتأمين السفر
[موسيقى]
هذه التكوينات الصخرية المذهلة أيضًا
تسمى مدينة الحجر وتعرف باسم
الباستا أو الباستيل وتقع في
حديقة سكسونية سويسرا الوطنية في ألمانيا
، وهي متصلة ببعضها البعض بواسطة
جسر من نوع باثس
، وتغطى صخور الحجر الرملي بالأشجار والشجيرات ،
وقد تم إنشاؤها عن طريق التعرية المائية على مدار
ملايين السنين.
تم إنشاء النسخة الأولى من الجسر في عام 1824
بالخشب ولكن في عام 1851 تم بناء نسخة
جديدة للمساعدة في زيادة مطردة في عدد
الزوار اليوم ، ويمكن رؤية أفضل جسر للعين
في مشاهد أفلام هوليوود البارزة
من The Chronicles of Narnia وتم
تصويره هنا.
يمكن التعرف على منصة العرض بسهولة في فندق بودابست الكبير
، حيث توجد أبراج الجسر على ارتفاع 650 قدمًا
فوق نهر إلبه  يبلغ ارتفاع mb up 487 درجة
وبسبب ارتفاعات مثل هذه ،
تعد الحديقة جزءًا من منطقة التسلق
والمشي لمسافات طويلة التي تمتد إلى
جمهورية التشيك منذ سقوط
جدار برلين قبل 30 عامًا ، وقد أصبح هذا الموقع
نقطة جذب مثيرة لجميع
الذين يزورون و  المنظر من الأعلى
يستحق التنزه سيرًا على الأقدام ، يُعد المشي على طول
الجسر نقطة ممتازة للحصول على
مناظر بانورامية للجبال
والمناظر الطبيعية الخلابة لساكسونيا ألمانيا
[موسيقى]
أنت